what do you think about just laying
maxwell into the trial and so on
again maybe the interesting story there
is
about the coverage
of the trial so like the story is more
complex and interesting than the actual
horrific acts themselves
so to me i don't maybe i'm not
knowledgeable enough
but
to me she's also truly evil
i don't know where to maybe you can help
me to figure out who is more evil
the uh
just like you said no the person says
it's okay it's okay that uh
helps
the evil doer or is it the evildoer
themselves i don't know but i think
she's a she scares me more than jeffrey
epstein somehow
yeah there's people like that in the
world i had a like a twitter poll do you
think it's more evil or less evil to
kill someone because you've been paid to
do it
and
and people the winning answer was more
evil and i said it was
less
because i think in that case you can
kind of check out you could be like this
isn't my i'm just doing a job yeah i i
don't you know you kind of can
i think in a sense
if you have a certain mindset like
intellect to remove yourself from the
situation i'm just a conduit uh when
you're talking like i haven't been
following her case that that much
just because you mostly watch cnn and
cnn is not covering it well i think
my broader point would be
people who are
untouchable and who know they're
untouchable
do
much worse things than those of us
who aren't that way can appreciate like
i'm i was just talking about on twitter
about rosemary kennedy
she was one of jfk's sisters
it's not clear whether she was
developmentally disabled or had uh like
depressive mental illness there was
something clearly off with her to some
capacity
and at age 23
they gave her a lobotomy
and the thing with the lobotomy is you
have to be conscious you can you don't
put you under so you have to be counting
backwards while they're scalpels in your
brain and they stop but
they stopped
they did too far she became mentally
like a two-year-old you know never had
bladder control for the rest of her life
couldn't really talk or walk
and when that happened they
just put her away to some home and they
never mentioned her again or they didn't
tell the brothers or sisters where she
went the lobotomy was only revealed in
1987
um and they pretended oh she's uh you
know in this home for kids with
special needs and it's just like
like that to me is very very scary
that someone could you know do this to
their that people are i saw people
respond like oh that was
you know cutting edge technology at the
time haha but i'm like i don't think
that that was really
uh done that that frequently or be
hearing more about it all these you know
botched lobotomies and my understanding
is lobotomies are
very hard to
like you they would want to do something
like a mass murderer or like like if
someone's really bad like if the
person's left an invalid like who cares
kind of situation but you're dealing
with something like this like
she's not killing people she's not
assaulting people
she's just difficult because she's
making your vaunted family look bad
so um so that's to you that's what is it
like psychopathy or something like that
like you don't care about
you just you you do horrific things and
you don't really care i can't diagnose
joe kennedy but
what i would say like with julian
maxwell i can't empathize because i
don't underst
first of all even in a positive sense i
don't know what it's like to be
grooming my son to be the president and
lost you know the other son in war i
don't know what that's like uh i don't
know what it's like to be so wealthy
like i have you have to give joe kennedy
credit because a lot of what he was
fighting for was to allow you know irish
people and catholic people acceptance
into like high society and he was up
against a lot of pressure with that and
he's like i'm gonna you know screw these
people i'm gonna be recognized and we're
gonna make people recognize so there's
somebody said for that but
i mean
i i can't relate to people like him
yeah
but i mean that like
is just terrifying like i mean one of
the big reasons i'm an anarchist is
like when you have someone who has that
sense of amount of power over somebody
else
a lot of times they're gonna do bad
things
and have no consequences
you